we were talking and you were telling me
about this great you were talking about
this great stand-up special that you did
and you were telling me that there was
some really funny stuff that you had to
cut yeah I was really surprised that and
it was for HBO HBO and you'd think HBO
you can pretty much talk about anything
on topless dragons yeah but apparently
the bad-boy stylings of Pete Holmes a
little too much what is it too much heat
what is it they made you cut out well
it's legal stuff I didn't know but
apparently you can't sing songs or you
can't even say songs you can't reference
music without paying the artists I
didn't know this because I have this
joke about how there's all this like
weird stuff in music if you think about
it it's not that bad I just go what's
going on with that song that Bruce
Springsteen song where he goes a little
girl is your daddy home why am i hearing
this in a Chipotle not when they were
recording it in the 70s no one on the
other side of the glass when he was just
like you did who no one was like yeah
weird man yeah yeah
is that no no no hear me out I got a bad
desire I forgot that that's for a dude
it's not it's not good it's everywhere
there's that Neil Diamond song we love
it you hear it
it's a Disneyland don't you have it on
in the pirate restaurant you'll just
you're like girl you'll be a woman at
the library why is that happening I
don't there shouldn't be music at the
life lawd you'll be a woman soon now
wait for that transition to be
completely free let me so much can't
count all the ways backs away